aber wir wollen jetzt pennsylvania
schauen denn dieser bundesstaat kann das
entscheidende zünglein an der waage sein
und unser kollege max die welt ist da
vor ort und berichtet uns einmal wie
angespannt oder vielleicht sogar
entspannt die stimmung dort ist ja also
nele entspannt würde ich die stimmung
nicht bezeichnen
wir haben in den letzten monaten immer
wieder über diese beiden lager in diesem
land gesprochen die sich ein stück weit
unversöhnlich gegenüberstehen und wenn
man so will
wir stellen jetzt zwischen diesen beiden
lagern der christian kommt jetzt einmal
und zeigt euch also was wir hier sehen
sind die unterstützer von donald trump
die sich versammelt haben vor der
konvent vor dem convention center in
pennsylvania da muss man wissen dort
drin ist ein wahllokal dort drin wurde
abgestimmt und dort drin wird noch immer
ausgezählt
das ist genau das was das trump lager
verhindern will julian hat es vorhin
erzählt die sind hier aufmarschiert
vorhin mit wenigen männern dann sind es
immer mehr geworden sie haben ihre
farben geholt ihre banner geholt und
werden ein stück weit von der polizei na
ja ich würde sagen um jeden geschützt
weil ich drücke uns mal ganz kurz
hierdurch so wir gehen mal ein paar
meter christian sind weil auf der
anderen seite stopp auf der anderen
seite das andere lager steht julian hat
das gesagt wenn der delphi etwa 80 20
für joe biden und das ja ja kann man
schon so sagen spiegelt sich auch ein
bisschen hier auf dieser demonstration
beiden lager deutlich größer mit
deutlich mehr anhänger wir gehen einfach
mal mit
und zeigen euch wie es hier aussieht
eigentlich den ganzen morgen schon seit
heute früh um 8 uhr haben sich hier
versammelt sprechen halten ansprachen
tanzen mit ja musik lauter musik ich
hoffe dass man mich überhaupt versteht
und so sind die beiden miteinander man
schreit auf einer nahen bereich noch
einmal zu zeigen da drüben das camp
lager getarnt getrennt vielleicht drei
vier meter voneinander die polizei mit
ich würde sagen 80 90 beamten im einsatz
ja und so ganz klar ist noch nicht wie
sich das verhalten wird ja also wie
gesagt den ganzen vormittag über war es
eher ruhig er entspannt aber gerade sind
mit neue leute von mir haben kraut boys
gesehen diese rechtsnationale
rechtsnationale gruppe die donald trump
unterstützt und da ist das reibung hier
reingekommen aber wir haben wörter
gehört die ich nicht wiederholen will
und das ist hier die stimmung das ist
die atmosphäre wir sehen da aufgebrachte
menschen die demonstrieren
gleichzeitig dachte ich für einen kurzen
moment deinen rucksack wäre eine
schusssichere weste bis ich gesehen habe
dass es tatsächlich einen rucksack ist
aber meine frage wie gefährlich wird
dass da heute noch wir haben ja auch in
den vergangenen tagen sehr heftige
bilder gesehen teilweise menschen mit
waffen
das waren in dem fall sondern trump
anhängern glaubst du ist runter heute
gewalt also ich hoffe wir brauchen keine
schusssicheren westen
und ganz ehrlich zu sein gerade aus
diesem lager recht den anhängern von joe
biden
das ist eigentlich eine positive
stimmung das ist auch ich würde sagen
die optimistische stimmung
wir waren von der woche in pennsylvania
da war hier da war ihr reibung das ist
die leute marschiert da waren die leute
stimmten hat angst davor dass die wahl
gestohlen wird ein abbau amerikaner ist
hier von der polizei erschossen wurden
vor einer woche auch das hat dazu
geführt dass die leute wahnsinnig sauber
waren jetzt eine woche später kurz nach
der wahl da muss man sagen die stimmung
in diesem lager hier deutlich besser
erreichen die stimmung den ganzen tag
über ist steht nicht unsere wahl sieht
jede stimme aus und kräht wir sehen hier
auf black box meter an das sozusagen ist
die stimmung jetzt gehen wir noch mal
rüber zum stammlager als wir das
schaffen haben
ich bin euch da nochmal zu zeigen
interessante an dem schwanz lager und
das stück weit auch etwas was wir in den
letzten drei wochen erlebt haben wie
diffus das lager ist wie unterschiedlich
wir haben gesehen mütter fischer wir
sehen kreta 15
wir haben gesehen veteranen für jump
evangelikale füttern
noch liegen für trump und jetzt haben
wir gerade noch mal eine ganz gute lücke
um ranzukommen
und da sieht man die wie unterschiedlich
das lager als junge frauen ältere frauen
wenn der familienväter vorhin war noch
als teenager hat man gesehen und das ist
sicherlich ein stück weit auf
sinnbildlich für das trump lager haben
das eben nicht nur aus weißem
ungebildeten männern besteht wie er so
oft der vorteil vorurteil gerade in
deutschland ist
eine letzte frage an dich wenn man jetzt
dort beide lager beobachtet wie du und
wenn du dort mit den menschen spricht
hast du das gefühl dass beide lager
immer noch fest davon überzeugt sind
dass sie gewonnen haben oder gewinnen
werden
ja ich glaube dass der captain daran
dass beide lager will sie sich nicht
gerade mit schimpfwörtern gegenseitig
anschreien sorry dass sie sich dann
gegenseitig als looser bezeichnen und
beide eigentlich die ganze zeit rufen
wir haben gewonnen sie haben gewonnen
deswegen jahr die die beiden lager sind
fest davon überzeugt dass sie als sieger
rausgehen und ich meine man muss sich
das vorstellen die wahl ist jetzt einige
tage her
es ist ein normaler arbeitstag und seit
heute morgen früh um 9 uhr stehen hier
die leute und schreien sich gegenseitig
an also das zeigt welche energie welche
welche dramatik und auch ja welche
welche begeisterung jeweils für die
kandidaten und für das unterschiedliche
lager hier besteht in vielen dank max
skive für uns also in philadelphia in
pennsylvania in dem bundesstaat auf den
wohl die allermeisten jetzt blicken wir
sind bild und wir liefern dir deine news
auf youtube zum nächsten video kommst du
hier
und vergiss bitte nicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren